I was deposited to awareness with an
abruptness normally reserved for the
newly-born a much like them my first
view of the world was enough to send me
into wracking sobs I attempted to recoil
to fall back to the nothing that I had
came from but found myself frozen my
body not my own only able to watch and
look at the horror at the world I now
found myself in cracked bricks and
blocks formed an endless road before me
while behind laid only a flat massive
black more dark and empty than the place
I had already come from stones and
clumps of masonry floated here and there
as if being frozen after being flung
free by some massive explosion the
yawning tubes dotted this narrow
cyclopean highway and the road had even
crumbled away in sections to reveal
gaping maws of oblivion it was not this
alien landscape that filled me with
horror while it gnawed and gnashed at
the edges of my strength of mind
it was the subtle awareness of the place
that caused me to recoil in my frozen
body everywhere have perceived faces
lead from the bricks the ground the
clouds everywhere eyes dull but
believing was a mocking predatory
awareness seemed to watch their vapid to
emptiness vanishing when perceived too
closely
faced with the blank nothing behind me
were the unknown horror before I forced
my unresponsive limbs forward each step
a jerky ordeal I kept my eyes locked
ahead seeing only the next step the next
stone never looking at the impossible
islands a floating decayed brick that
drifted over me nor at the mocking faces
laughing at my plight from every crevice
merely steps into my journey I
rose nearly recoiling back to beat at
the blank nothing wall behind me rather
than take another step or before had and
not but crumbling road there was now
another traveler it shambled forward
sliding low hundreds rotten wait pulpy
black lumps feet slowly dragging and
along the road to staring blank eyes
floated in the bloated fungal mass of
its body fixed on me with unseen focus
of a mind as alien to mine as a deep-sea
worm I stood frozen and uncomprehending
as it slowly strode forward its wheezing
body barely bigger than that of a child
its glaring eyes were fixed on me the
puppy thing slowly drawing closer I
could not move dirt read would result
only an eventual captured by the thing
but to advance would mean crossing it
and the thought of touching that thing
the decision was made for me for is the
thing drew close I was galvanized into
action by horror or rage I left forward
screaming nonsense and struck at that
bloated body I kicked and stumped at it
crushing the flabby and far too soft
flesh underneath me sobbing in horror as
I felt the flesh touched me
then melt away rotting to nothingness in
seconds believing such an unclean memory
in me that I knew I would feel that dull
soggy weight against me long after even
the sweet cold embrace him beyond after
that I ran I ran and cursed whatever
blind faded brought me here an
obliteration my memory my life and left
only the road
we had terminal Road I would have cried
I've balled up and throw myself down one
of the analyst pits that broken open the
road but I was compelled to continue
legs continuing in a jerky rhythm that
propelled me over the crumbling brick
leaping across the pits
even as I secretly wished to fall into
their depths and obliterate the road the
faces and myself as I ran and jumped I
came to one of the thick twisted tubes
that dotted the claustrophobic landscape
I thought to look in for a moment
curiosity fighting to overcome my almost
manic desire to be free of this place
but upon hearing a strange shuffling and
gurgling coupled with a deep bass pulse
from the bowels of the black pipe I
decided against it squeezed it round as
soon as I was passed there was a sudden
rush of air behind me followed by a
sharp oddly muffled snap as if two iron
bars wrapped in Conda be thrown together
behind me I did not turn merely using
this to further galvanize my stuttering
walk ignoring that continued snapping
and rustling as it faded behind me far
ahead I saw long glassy stare leading up
and beyond it would look like a squat
dwelling made of the same crumbling
brick as the road while I feared what
may lie inside the idea of someone else
some other person with which to share
this horrible place with filled me with
the first hope I felt in hours I ran
eyes fixed on that stare and soared
across the final gap
it was midway across the abyss when I
saw the thing was waiting on the other
side it was a twisted parody of some
kind of a reptile its elongated face was
filled with a dim sort of Menace and his
mouth yawned in anticipation of my
reaching the other side the jagged edge
is glinting as I made a choking squeal
its body balanced on to squat shapeless
legs a shell hard cracked flesh encasing
the bulbous torso two stunted limbs
projected through the flaking shale
coated in fibrous growths and slowly
shifted and a sick mockery of wings I
screamed and twisted trying in vain to
return to the far edge but it was too
late then my struggles were enough to
bring me short slamming into the hard
wall of the pit nothing above me
shrieking in frustration as I fell down
and down spinning into the endless
blackness I felt the dark and clothes
around me
however seconds before the emptiness can
provide me a final solace I suddenly
remembered endless roads Lake Sapphire
crumbling tombs filled with rotting
shambling bones of beasts hazy forms of
glowing slickly light following in the
dark
floating networks of ancient wood
drifting in a hot sky it all came back
to me in a flood then remembered
somewhere I had been what I had done and
knowing that it would continue I do not
know how long I have done this nor what
I have done to earn this
only that I must walk the road forever
you